last year was hell it was my first time
eating Nigeria Angelou actually in all
seriousness I was going through a lot of
personal turmoil faced with enormous
stress I suffered an anxiety attack on
some days I could do no work on other
days I just wanted to lay in my bed and
cry my doctor asked if I'd like to speak
with a mental health professional about
my stress and anxiety mental health I
clammed up and violently shook my head
in protest
I felt a profound sense of shame I felt
the weight of stigma I have a loving
supportive family an incredibly loyal
friends yet I could not entertain the
idea of speaking to anyone about my
feeling of pain I felt suffocated by the
widgett architecture or the African
masculinity people have real problems
angle get over yourself the first time I
had mental health I was a boarding
school students flash of the boots from
Ghana at the pedi school in New Jersey I
had just gone through the brutal
experience of losing seven loved ones in
the same month the school nurse
concerned about what I had gone through
god bless her so she inquired about my
mental health if she meant her I thought
- in Oulu I'm an African man like
okonkwo and things fall apart
we African men need a process no Express
I emotions we deal with our problems we
deal with our problems I called my
brother and loved about evil people
white people and there are strange
diseases depression a Dede and those
weird things going up in West Africa
when people use the term mental what
came to mind was a madman with Dead Sea
dreadlock hair bumbling around half
naked on the streets we all know this
man
appearance warned us about him mummy
mummy why's he mad drugs if you even
look at drugs you end up like him come
down with pneumonia and your mother will
rush you to the nearest hospital for
medical treatment but dare to declare
depression and your local pasta will be
driving out demons and blaming witches
in your village according to the World
Health Organization mental health is
about being able to cope with the normal
stresses of life to work productively
and fruitfully and to be able to make a
contribution to your community mental
health includes our emotional
psychological and a social well-being
globally 75% of all melt or mental
illness cases can be found in low-income
countries yet most African governments
invest less than 1% of their healthcare
budget on mental health even worse we
have a severe shortage of psychiatrists
in Africa Nigeria for example is
estimated to have 200 in a country of
almost 200 million in all of Africa 90%
of our people lack access to treatment
as a
so we suffer in solitude silenced by
stigma we as Africans often respond to
mental health with distance ignorant
guilt fear and anger in a study
conducted by a ball a bola de Flores
directly asking what is the cause of
mental illness 34% of Nigerian
respondents cited drug misuse 19% said
divine wrath and the will of God
12% witchcraft and spiritual possession
but few cited other known causes of
mental illness like genetics
socioeconomic status war conflicts or
the loss of a loved one the
stigmatization against mental illness
often results in the ostracizing and
demonizing of sufferers photojournalist
Robyn Hammond has documented some of
these abuses in Uganda in Somalia and
here in Nigeria for me the stigma is
personal
in 2009 I received a frantic call in the
middle of the night my best friend in
the world
a brilliant philosophical charming hip
young man was diagnosed with
schizophrenia
I witnessed some of the friends we've
grown up with recoil
I heard the Snickers
I heard the whispers did you hear he has
gone mad
he stopped Oh to the Varga Tori
demeaning commentary about his condition
we would never say about someone with
cancer or someone with malaria somehow
when it comes to mental illness are
ignorant eviscerates or empathy I stood
by his side as his community isolated
him but I loved never wavered tacitly I
became passionate about mental health
inspired by his plight I helped found
the mental health special interest
alumni group at my college and during my
tenure as a resident tutor and graduate
school I supported many undergraduates
with their mental health challenges
I saw African students struggle and
unable to speak to anyone even with this
knowledge and with their stories in tow
I intend struggled and could not speak
to anyone when I face my own anxieties
so deep is our fear of being the madman
all of us but we Africans especially
need to realize that our mental
struggles do not be tracked from our
virility not as our trauma taint our
strength we need to see mental health as
important as physical health we need to
stop suffering and silence we must stop
stigmatizing disease and traumatizing
the afflicted talk to your friends talk
to your loved ones talk to health
professionals be vulnerable do so with
the confidence that you are not alone
[Music]
speak up if you are struggling being
honest about how we feel does not make
us weak it makes us human it is time to
end the stigma associated with mental
illness
so the next time you hear mental do not
just think of the madman think of me
thank you